the top speed is pods about 25
kilometers an hour that's not where
we're gonna be operating the range of
but that's what is potential and it can
do about 35 kilometers on a single
charge
so more than enough to getting up and
down this is the medicine dopamine
central quite acute ours we've got about
10 on site today and so we always reuse
all the containers you can see behind us
and the containers are for two reasons
obviously storage is one but the second
is as you can observe from the video
it's quite a barren site and so it
doesn't really mimic a city centre very
well so they're strategically placed for
the lidar so in town when we're driving
around there's always going to be walls
buildings and trees to bounce off and
that's how you navigate through lidar
but so that's where we are so you create
a map so you have to travel around a
couple of times you could do it off one
but one doesn't work very well because
if there's something in the way say a
burden lidar or someone standing the way
that would be picked up in an
environment and then when the pod would
travel around it would be looking for
that person again so you've got to do it
a couple of times to basically remove
them and only get static features that
are always going to be there so there's
a couple of things a couple of senses
here that's lighter out there that is
our navigation light off so that's
bouncing off the containers that's how
it navigates we also will have lidar
down here we're currently looking at
different types so there are internal
lidar indoor light ours and there are
external light ours and as you can
imagine internal light I don't deal with
sunlight very well so that's why we're
having to experiment with outdoor lidar
and basically find the one that best
suits our needs there's thousands of
applications for a lidar and there's
quite a few makers so we're finding the
right ones the whole reason for our
project the goal is to make them
affordable to councils you know budgets
can't are not limitless so we're trying
to find a way how do you provide an
excellent service with good quality
whilst remaining like attainable for
councillors really so there's a lot of
options for lidar as you probably
imagine that's finding which one suits
our needs which one performs well
without going beyond the grasp of like
council bollards basically how do
right we're gonna have a QR code scanner
here and you would provide it you use
your phone to access the pod we have
buttons on the inside and the outside so
they open the doors and so we would we
would get in and it would know that
urine because you scan for the purposes
the video we're gonna show it on laptop
because it's easy to see yeah yeah with
most heavy machinery and tests test
vehicles you have a Deadman switch so
that's if anything goes wrong or some
reason we need to stop you let go of the
trigger and it stopped so that's what
I'm doing here I'm not controlling the
vehicle I'm just holding the the dead
man without the kilometre track of our
site and as you can see on the laptop
now so you're seeing of is the circles
are each Waypoint and so waypoints have
a location on the x y&z and they also
have a speed and that's the speed of the
board as it goes to it we would map the
center in lidar and you would also map
it through waypoints it would then
compute its own route if you wanted to
go from one spinning place to another
there would be waypoints for that so we
need to map the whole Center basically
and so right now it's got about 60
waypoints for our site and this is about
two meters a second and the idea of
project is to basically be twice walking
speed that's what the the council of
specifications we want and that's what
we want to do because we're operating on
read ways and still open to the public
and cyclists so there's an appropriate
speed that we must follow we go out to
the train station there's lots and lots
of people and we've offered a few people
that so far there's a big Santander HQ
here so we've had many people add event
and people always want a waypoint to
Wetherspoons and fit on a Friday evening
quite soon we're going to be doing auto
most trials outside in the
in public we're gonna start with no
passengers and then we're going to
slowly have passengers and more stops to
our trials we envisage a thing with
coins pod club so we're going to take a
hundred people for a kind of beta phase
so that we have to trial vehicles with
destinations they like on our on our
circuit and by September we hope to
offer a public service yes the site's
been abandoned since Milton Keynes was
built so it's out of 50 years of misuse
really particularly in this section is
very bit but the site offers just over e
kilometer a private track and it's in
such a perfect location it's quite bumpy
here in a way it's quite good because
this is much worse than any of the red
wave we'd be running in so we can really
put the pod through its paces here the
proper test Ron yeah a proper test right
exactly and if you can deal with this
it'll have absolutely no problem and
centre you drop me along and you
suddenly realize that you need to go so
sure we have a service has a built-in
council feature and so that's part of
why we're here
later in coming months we're going to be
talking with the public a lot and part
of that point is getting their feedback
and seeing what they'd like to see so
we've already started that so we've
talked about you know the QR scanner and
ease of the use also ramps with the
vehicle so if you were in a wheelchair
you could as easily access it as as
anyone else so yeah I'm looking forward
to that because it's kind of your chance
to let the public really have a look
tear down at the vehicle because you can
have the you can have what exactly what
you think works but it's always good to
get the public who will eventually be
the end users of it they'll have their
say this is the software used to the
pond to navigate and so this ties
directly into all of the internals and
the steering controller the brakes all
of those control from here so if i zoom
in on one particular waypoints this is a
waypoint of one as you can see it's got
two meters a second so that's a speed is
going to go through this arrow
and you can place them with a with a 2d
nav goal and give it its orientation and
then the important bit is you've got a
compute before every route this is the
loop it's going to do I'm probably
wondering what all of these lines are so
this is actually the lidar map so this
is how I navigate so each rectangular
here is one of the containers when we're
driving in lidar it's looking for these
objects the dark black outlines are
something it's 100 censures there is
very little kind of pass-through it's
all reflected and so that's ideally what
we'd aim for the gray so it's on a kind
of black scale so the gray is is
something it's less raw so if you did it
right through a window it would come out
great because some gets reflected
because it's not a solid object and
white obviously it ignores about
shooting into open space and you you
can't navigate off that okay so
sometimes did you pick up a bush but
because the bush is quite large and it's
not going anywhere
there's actually quite a good
navigational feature yep obviously those
are good landmarks but looks like the
majority is done by GPS would that be
right this this right now is only
running off GPS that loop just then was
purely off GPS because that's what we're
working on today and we have said we
that's what I was saying so we're in the
process of kind of tying them together
because right now we're confident that
it can navigate off GPS alone and it can
navigate off lidar and as we're meshing
it together we're also going to start
doing autonomous runs in Milton Keynes
and so the the GP the GPS is so
obviously via satellite at the base
station but it communicates through a
network it's a mess yet so make sure
it's got coverage wherever yeah we can
get a visual representation of the
strength of the GPS that we're receiving
the blue is order might not come through
on the camera they're individual ticks
so the GPS is in constant communication
with at the pause so if that blue line
disappears we know we're not getting the
coverage we need and the probable
actually stop our number one goal right
now is to make sure the two bottom
levels of navigation so the lidar
the GPS can navigate independently and
if they can independent independently
navigate obviously when you put them
together they're just that more and more
safe so that's the girl right now so I
think the fleet here is about 6,000
kilometers though the last couple of
months and so we're continually building
that they're still building pods in in
comments rooms shipping them down here
and put them through the paces
and I should caveat this by saying I'm
going we're talking in general terms
each operating system with us Windows
Linux Mac or iOS BSD insert your
favorite operating system here that you
probably